everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
12 of our coverage of the 2016
candidates tournament winner of this
tournament does go on to face Magnus
Carlsen in November for the World
Championships it seems like for the past
five or six rounds that we've had a
three to four man race with everyone
just taking turns being at the top of
the leaderboard around 11 we had a
pretty epic match we had vision on take
on saratoga caddie a kin two of the top
players vision on came out on top so
coming into this round abyssion on in
Fabiano car hana are tied for first and
saturday karyakin
is only a half a point behind them so
today's match why it's gonna be played
by knock more from the United States
although in theory out of contention for
first just way too far behind once to
make at least a decent showing these
last three rounds we do play 14 rounds
in this tournament just not having a
good tournament so far that he's gonna
be playing the white pieces his opponent
to vision on playing the black pieces
looking to kind of solidify his spot at
the top of the leaderboard so we're
gonna get into it starts out with pawn
to c4 the English opening pawn e5 Knight
c3 Knight f6 Knight f3 knight c6 and we
saw a very similar match early on in a
tournament if you haven't kind of
watched some of the earlier rounds if
you watch table bursts Levon Aronian
they played a very similar match even
upwards to the first eight or so move so
we'll kind of go through pawn to g3
fianchetto the bishop on the kingside
bishop down here a b4 attacking the
knight now the Knights gonna come up
here to a d5 and then pawn to e4 there's
such an awkward spot for white to
immediately have to worry about this
pawn all up in his business over here
with this knight a really really nice
support so Knight over here to h4 Castle
on the kingside at bishop here g2 pawn
d6 and then pawn a3 and this is the
first deviation from the top lob Aronian
game that we saw early on it and you can
be assured that both the players in this
tournament that the eight contenders but
also there
so usually they bring some people with
them that are watching the other games
they've studied with them for months
coming up into this tournament they've
seen all the previous stuff they've
looked at different variations and see
if they can find small little tweaks and
so my guess is they study this
particular game and saw okay Ponda a3 is
probably a better move in that
particular game Tobel have played at
night to a b4 and then night recaptured
here on before at a blob would go on to
lose the game as white so Nakamura kind
of looked at that and said upon to a3 I
think is a better variation so after a
pawn 283 a bishop back here to c5 castle
on the Kings side and then a rook here
to e8 just solidifying more so on this
pawn on e4 very important piece for
efficient on in the center of the board
Nakamura continues upon III and then
pawn g5 pretty aggressive move from
vision on extending his protection in
front of his king to have a nice little
attack on the night here on h4 and this
knight on age 4 can't really go anywhere
I'd like to kind of retreat back to f3
this is the normal square for the knight
controlling the center of the board but
it's there's this pawn here on e4 is
just so difficult to deal with it can't
come here to g6 clearly because the
pawns can't come here to f5 because the
LightSquared bishop for black would just
take it so all-in-all macklemore is in a
tough spot but he does have the option
to counter-attack his opponent so that's
really the only thing that he can do
right now he starts out with pawn to b4
forcing the bishop to come back here and
then Bishop to b2 if we look at there's
a few options I'll go through some of
them and why they're all bad but it
could decide just to go ahead and take
here on b6 it takes on b6 then the pawn
takes here on b6 and then white has to
move and there's no more threats that he
can really do this Knight is going to
fall on board there's that option the
other option is to go ahead and take
here on f6 the problem there is all of a
sudden the Queen's gonna come take on f6
this is gonna be extremely bad the
Knights going to fall there's just no
way to really combat this but instead
he could play Bishop here to be to and
that stops some of this stuff because
the pawn can't just take on h4 because
now Knights that you know the bishop
could take or even more powerful than
that the knight could take care on f6
check for king at this rook irani 8th is
being protected by the bishop so the
Queen can't take it and then if we see
King to f8 King to h8 just gets crazier
because there's the discovered attack
once the Knights moves but if we see
King to f8 then all of a sudden Knight
h7 check because the King comes back
potentially Knight f6 we could continue
this but then all of a sudden the
Queen's gonna get involved into the game
it gets really really bad there's just
no protection over here for black so he
can't take that night right away here on
h4 so he has to kind of figure out what
he is going to do on board he decides to
go ahead and take this night here on d5
o which is which is great Nakamura can
respond pawn takes here on d5 and then
hey if you want to take a my Knights
that's gonna be completely okay I'll
take your knight and then I'm not down
in material so this is really the only
way that Nakamura had to continue and so
this unit has some options here as far
as how he continues there's two more
there's two main moves he could play
Knight to e5 nice little outpost here he
does have a palm protection so if the
bishop doesn't want to take that's gonna
be completely okay
he has the ability to come down here to
d4 he knows that he's probably going to
lose his knight but that's okay because
he's gonna gain a knight over here he
probably chooses the worse of the two
options he plays Knight to d4 it's not
on outpost at all and I really just
don't like this move in general just
allows his opponent to take it but
macklemore decides to first play pawn to
d3 he knows that he can take this Knight
if he wants to there's no way really
around that if he wants to try to hold
on to it Knight coming back here to b5
isn't gonna work because just pawn to a4
the Knights still going to fall so he
recognized this and said I can just
having a little in between move pawn to
d3 first then we see the pawn take on h4
pawn first take on e4 he knows this
Knight is still his whatever he wants it
so the Knights gonna come back here to
e6 pawn takes on e6 and then rook comes
down here to e6 does not want to lose
another pawn in front of his King so
instead decides to go ahead and take
with his rook here on e6 and then palm
pushing forward to e5 and this is
another nice little move from Nakamura
is it pushed forward in the center of
the board the pawn can't take here
because the Queen's going to take up
here on d8 that's gonna be extremely bad
this does open up the door for the
LightSquared bishop to get involved into
the game and all of a sudden white's
doing a better job of controlling the
center of the board as soon as this pawn
takes all of a sudden this dark square
bishop is gonna be just barreling down
on his opponent you can see this dark
square bishop it has two pawns to get
through before it's really putting a lot
of pressure on his opponent so
macklemore definitely has much more
defense in front of his king we're
fishing on although he had a nice little
attack all of a sudden it kind of looks
like he's gonna have a lot of pain
coming his way as far as an attack from
Nakamura so after the pawn takes the
pawn recaptures here from the H pawn it
is a little worse just if you take with
your pawn on g3 the Queen comes down
here to g5 double attack with the bishop
and the Queen here the pawn can't move
so pretty much the bishops gonna come
down here to e3 I'm just in a tough
tough spot for for Nakamura so he
correctly decides to go ahead and take
with his H pawn now the Queen comes down
to g5 but it's not nearly as strong as
they attack since this pawn on f2 is
protecting that the pond does take on d6
the roofs gonna capture here and then
Queen to b3 so starting to line up a lot
of his material against his opponent's
king side which is somewhat decimated
right now the LightSquared bishop still
has not got involved this rogue over
here on a8 is not doing anything on
board a pawn to h5 I really don't like
this move from from fishing on I don't
understand why he decides to take his
already tough position he has to deal
with so much
and extend his pawns even further I
think it's time to kind of buckle down
your Titan material but you probably
have a worse position play rook over
here h6 protect it's keep the pawns on
the seventh rank don't increase them any
further down that the path but instead
we see pawn to h5 looking to kind of
blow up on the Kings side of the board
we're here to d1 attacking the rook and
then rook to h6 another move I don't
necessarily like I think if you're gonna
play pawn to h5 you got to just commit
continue down the board pawn to h4 and
let's just go with it but rook two to h6
I mean usually once your rooks behind
your pawns if they're in the center of
the board you're kind of pushing it up
and you're trying to you know protect
that but over here on that on the h-file
that's not necessarily what you're
looking to do especially when your
opponent's just going to be very very
aggressively attacking rook here to d5
so Nakamura starts to attack the Queen
and now it is essentially just get the
pieces involved into the game as much as
possible Queen here to c4 just
solidifying his position a little bit
more getting allowing himself to get his
queen involved over to the King sides
getting the attack a bishop down to g4 I
like the light square bishop involved
into the action I also like it involved
ten moves ago right now it's not doing a
whole heck of a lot Queen over here f4
rook g6 just trying to add a little bit
of protection to the king side but then
rook to e5 forcing the Queen to move and
then Bishop to e4 attacking the rook
there's just too much going on once this
rook can get more involved into the game
we have too many attacks the star square
bishop here is just too powerful in this
particular spot mission on decided to go
ahead and resign so kind of crazy the
last four matches vichy not have had
he's won two and lost two dudes not
trying to draw at all so kudos to him
for having some exciting games you have
someone like a nice giri who has tied
every round every single round anon he's
goin for glory now sometimes he does
resigned a little bit earlier
if he doesn't like the position that
he's in like today although it is
definitely a losing position but all all
his matches are exciting so busy and on
drops back in the standings he did not
improve at all Sergey karyakin
he won today so he lost yesterday to be
chignon he won today so he is now tied
in first place with Fabiana caruana who
tied today so in the lead we have serra
da and we have Fabiano and then half a
point behind them we have this year non
so that's pretty much the three-man race
one of those is more than likely going
to win the tournament so last two rounds
are gonna be very very critical so make
sure you definitely check those out
round 13 and 14 then we will crown a
champion and that player will go on to
play Magnus Carlsen so hopefully you got
enjoy this match definitely a more
exciting game that I was expecting out
of a the English opening but thanks
everyone for watching I'll see you guys
in the next one